in this video we're going to talk about  the concept of a loop don't be  intimidated if you don't understand  everything that I've written down that's  okay  the concept of a loop is that it's a way  to traverse a set of data what that  means is that you have an array like  this one bare array which is true a  boolean will key a string 42 and 0 if we  want to go through all of these  I wrote a loop here this is a for loop  again you don't have to know what this  means exactly what I've written here  basically means that it will go through  every single one of these and every time  there's an entry it will add one to my  counter it can be a lot more complicated  than this and it does and that's ok what  you need to know about loops is if you  have a set of data that you want to  access every single one of the things  inside of it but you don't want to write  the code that many times that's when you  use a loop